[PENCIL SCRIBBLING]
[TYPEWRITER]
[FILM REEL WHIRRING]
- So this was the first
folder that I pulled,
and this is a folder
that is a bill of sale.
And it's a bill of sale for a
woman whose name was Thankfull.
And her name only shows up
on this bill of sale once,
and it's Thankfull, Negro wench.
And what was most powerful
and upsetting about this
was that here, I was
holding a document that
held the legal bonds
of another person.
And this document was
creased, and folded,
and I thought to myself, how
precious this document would
have been if Thankfull
could have gotten it
and destroyed it.
And how this document
had to be held in a place
where she couldn't get it.
And when I look at
all these folds,
what did they do after
they signed this contract?
Did he fold it up and
put in his back pocket
and take Thankfull with him?
And then what
happened to Thankfull?
And that is something
that I don't know.
And unless this
document survives,
nobody recognizes the
individual experience
of those that have
been enslaved.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[PENCIL SCRIBBLING]